en este vídeo vamos a hablar de rectas
de regresión pero no es la primera vez
que hablamos de rectas de regresión así
que es la eia de recta de regresión que
es ajena te encargó que veas los vídeos
de introducción en esta ocasión quiero
que pensemos en cómo hacer inferencias a
partir de una recta de regresión ahora
bien si la idea de inferencia
estadística o de prueba de hipótesis te
son ajenas una vez más también te
encargó que veas esos vídeos y bueno
digamos que existe una asociación
positiva entre el número o el tamaño de
un zapato y la altura así que haremos
una gráfica en el eje horizontal tenemos
el tamaño de los zapatos y pondremos
algunos valores 21 centímetros 22
centímetros 23 centímetros 24
centímetros 25 centímetros 26 27 28 29
30 y 31 de 32 centímetros y podemos
seguir y en el eje y pondremos la
así que pongamos algunos valores un
metro cuarenta un metro cincuenta un
metro sesenta un metro setenta 180 190
dos metros y puedo seguir y seguir y
seguir y ahora para ver si existe una
asociación tomaremos una muestra así que
tomaremos una muestra aleatoria de 20
personas de toda la población y en los
vídeos siguientes hablaremos de las
condiciones necesarias para hacer una
inferencia apropiada digamos que estas
20 personas son estos 20 puntos tal vez
aquí tengamos a un niño por acá a un
adulto que tiene pies más grandes y es
más alto y después tengo 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 puntos
ya tenemos estos 20 datos representados
como puntos y lo que nos gustaría hacer
es meterlos en una computadora o también
lo podremos hacer a mano aunque
actualmente tenemos computadoras que lo
hacen por nosotros
la computadora intentará ajustar una
recta de regresión y hay muchas técnicas
para encontrarla pero una típica es en
general intentar minimizar la distancia
al cuadrado entre cada uno de estos
puntos y la recta y esta recta de
regresión tiene una ecuación como toda
recta y estamos tentados a decir que es
ye sombrero este sombrero nos dice que
estamos hablando de una recta de
regresión es igual a la ordenada al
origen a más la pendiente multiplicada
por nuestra variable x por lo tanto aquí
está nuestra a ahora bien para ser muy
claros si tomamos otra muestra entonces
obtendremos una recta diferente es más
podemos llamarle a la primera muestra y
el subíndice uno a subíndice uno b
subíndice uno y por lo tanto esta de
aquí sería a subíndice uno pero imagina
que tomamos otra muestra de 20 personas
déjame ponerlas
am 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
17 18 19 y 20 y ahora intentamos ajustar
la una recta a estos puntos bueno esta
recta se podría ver algo así podría
tener una pendiente y una ordenada al
origen ligeramente diferentes por lo
tanto podríamos decir que para la
segunda muestra tenemos una nueva recta
que va a tener la ecuación lledó
sombrero igual a 20 s 2 + b sobre índice
de 2 por equis es decir cada vez que
tomemos una muestra
podemos obtener resultados diferentes
para estos valores que esencialmente son
estadísticos recuerda los estadísticos
son cosas que podemos obtener de las
muestras y que intentan estimar los
parámetros poblacionales verdaderos
pero en este caso cuáles serían los
parámetros poblacionales verdaderos que
queremos estimar bueno imagina un mundo
en donde somos capaces de encontrar la
relación lineal verdadera o no sé tal
vez exista una relación lineal verdadera
entre el tamaño del zapato y la estatura
y bueno en teoría esta la podríamos
obtener si pudiéramos medir a todos los
seres humanos del planeta y para anclar
dependiendo de cómo definas una
población ya que podrían ser todas las
personas vivas en el planeta o todas las
personas que hayan vivido en el planeta
tierra no lo sé esto empieza a parecer
no tan práctico pero digamos que podemos
entonces tendremos miles de millones de
puntos para una población verdadera
ahora si quisiéramos ajustar una recta
de regresión podríamos pensarla como la
recta de regresión verdadera para la
población
esta sería sombrero igual am y para ser
claros que esta es la ordenada al origen
y está la pendiente que son nuestros
parámetros poblacionales verdaderos en
lugar de poner a am pongamos alfa en
lugar de poner a b
pongamos beta alfa más beta x pero es
muy difícil saber con exactitud los
valores de alta y de beta y por eso los
estimamos con las ips con base en una
muestra ahora lo que es interesante
teniendo esto en mente es que podemos
empezar a hacer inferencias con base en
nuestra muestra por ejemplo podemos
decir que b 2 es poco probable que sea
exactamente igual a beta pero con qué
confianza podemos decir que al menos
existe una relación lineal positiva o
una relación lineal distinta de cero o
podemos crear un intervalo de confianza
alrededor de este estadístico que nos dé
una buena idea de dónde está el
parámetro poblacional verdadero
bueno la respuesta es sí para lograrlo
usemos las mismas ideas que trabajamos
con inferencias con base en proporciones
o con bases medias la forma en la que
podemos hacer una inferencia por ejemplo
para la pendiente verdadera de esta
recta de regresión poblacional será
primero tomar la muestra obtener la
pendiente como por ejemplo b sub 20 es
de 2 y después crear un intervalo de
confianza alrededor de ese parámetro por
lo tanto nuestro intervalo de confianza
estará basado en algún valor crítico x
idealmente la desviación estándar de la
distribución muestral para este
estadístico que en este caso será la
pendiente de la recta de la regresión
muestral pero como no sabemos con
exactitud cuál es este valor no lo
sabemos de una manera precisa para
nuestra muestra entonces lo vamos a
estimar con lo que se conoce como el
error estándar del estadístico y vamos a
profundizar en esta idea en vídeos
futuros
y como aquí estamos estimando vamos a
usar aquí un valor t crítico los cuales
hemos estudiado anteriormente ahora con
base en el nivel de confianza que
queremos tener digamos un 95 por ciento
y en los grados de libertad que vamos a
ver que salen de cuántos datos tenemos
podemos encontrar este valor y a partir
de nuestra muestra podemos encontrar
este otro valor y también este otro y ya
con esto podemos construir un intervalo
de confianza también veremos qué podemos
hacer pruebas de hipótesis podemos decir
que nuestra hipótesis nula es que no hay
una relación lineal distinta de cero o
que la pendiente verdadera de la recta
de regresión poblacional es igual a cero
y la hipótesis alternativa será que la
pendiente verdadera de la recta de
regresión poblacional es mayor que cero
en el caso de tener una relación
positiva o que es distinta de cero
y después lo que haremos será suponiendo
que la hipótesis no le es verdadera
podemos buscar cuál es la probabilidad
de obtener que este estadístico sea al
menos tan extremo o más extremo que este
valor de 2 y si esa probabilidad está
por debajo de un cierto umbral
rechazaremos la hipótesis nula y
sugeriremos la alternativa así que estos
dos pasos ya los hemos hecho
anteriormente en donde creamos un
intervalo de confianza alrededor de este
estadístico o donde llevamos a cabo una
prueba de hipótesis haciendo
suposiciones acerca de un parámetro
verdadero la única diferencia aquí es
que el parámetro que estamos tratando de
estimar serán los parámetros para una
recta de regresión poblacional teórica y
lo haremos usando estos estadísticos
muestrales para una recta de regresión
muestral en fin continuaremos con todo
esto en el siguiente vídeo